et pour revenir sur cette démission du
gouvernement libanais la politologue et
historien na li namur nehmé enseignante
à l'université de beyrouth nous a
rejoint l'unam urnes et mais merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors cette démission du gouvernement
libanais est-ce qu'elle était inévitable
finalement je pense que depuis la visite
d' emmanuel macron oui elle est devenue
inévitable parce que le président
français a parlé d'une façon très dure
au vos politiciens aux hauts dirigeants
libanais et ça a provoqué des émeutes
extrêmement violente et je pense que
jamais il n'ya eu des émeutes aussi
violente et que ça était fortement
encouragé par le discours du président
macron ensuite il ya eu ce jour-là le
dimanche on dont vous avez parlé il ya
eu l'occupation de plusieurs ministères
et il ya eu les démissions de des
ministères dont les livres dans les
ministères ont été occupés le ministre
des affaires étrangères en premier donc
ce que vous nous dites finalement c'est
que c'est le président français les mots
du président français qui ont convaincu
hassan diable de démissionner avec son
gouvernement
non pas du tout les mots du président
français on diminue et la force du
gouvernement ils ont beaucoup à février
le gouvernement parce que vous savez
quand quelqu'un vient vous pariez
d'euros d'oat et qu'il y à des émeutes
contre vous forcément se fortifie les
les amitiés il y à des manifestants et
des métiers alors à quoi assiste-t-on
selon vous un pays qui entrent en train
de s'enfoncer davantage encore plus dans
la crise politique où finalement au
début d'un renouveau
moi je ne crois pas vraiment aux
révolutions violentes parce que la haine
n'amène que l'inde
les jeunes peuvent certains jeunes
peuvent y croire moi je
n'y crois pas parce que je n'ai pas vu
dans ma vie une révolution violente qui
n'a pas beaucoup fait souffrir les
populations
je crois aux révolutions qui viennent
d'en haut
je crois aux révolutions de style de
celle de gorbatchev
c'est le genre de révolution qui se fait
dans 10 ans dans la joie qui ne voient
pas le peuple malheureux qui ne pas
verser de sang en plus il ya un adage
qui dit que quand une révolution est
nécessaire elle est impossible et quand
elle est possible c'est qu'elle n'est
pas nécessaire c'est que les réformes
peuvent se faire autrement
or il se trouve que ce gouvernement est
le plus réformateur de ceux qui sont
ceux qui se sont succédé ces dernières
années or c'est lui qui en train
d'écoper tous ceux qui tout ce dont les
autres se sont rendus coupables
je vais vous donner un exemple le
ministre pendant le président de la
chambre nabih berry est au pouvoir
depuis trente ans et il a été de tous
les gouvernements
il est devenu extrêmement riche et il
avait commencé en étant pas riche du
tout et puis soudain il
il devient quelqu'un de bien et les gens
qui n'ont pas participé aux
gouvernements auparavant deviennent des
gens très mauvais je ne comprends pas le
problème c'est que maintenant c'est un
mouvement moi on est en train de payer
les vols de 30 ans les privations les
actions durant 30 ans est ce que cette
annonce du gouvernement donc cette
démission du gouvernement selon vous
est-ce qu'elle va calmer la colère de la
rue et j'en serais assez étonné parce
que déjà il ya eu une démission d'un
gouvernement précédent qui était
beaucoup moins bon que celui là et ça
n'a pas calmé
en fait le saut qui ce qui pose problème
c'est que vous avez les responsables de
corruption d
et des crimes des vols des années
précédentes ne sont pas ne subissent pas
des manifestations ils subissent pas des
émeutes ils sont pas insulter il ya
juste certains ceux qui ont rapport avec
le gouvernement avec le pouvoir qu'ils
le sont maintenant
on peut critiquer moi j'ai beaucoup de
choses à redire mais on ne peut pas
accuser le gouvernement actuel des
crimes des trente ans précédents comme a
fait le président matheron quelles sont
les réformes finalement qui ont été
faites et peut-être pas suffisamment vu
par le peuple libanais il y en a eu en
sept mois ce gouvernement est le temps
oui certainement il y à déjà ce que le
ministre de l'économie a fait avec le
ministre des finances et ils ont dressé
un plan de réforme que le fonds
monétaire international a accepté et
donc c'était un bon plein puisque se
plaint visait à éponger les dettes en
récupérant l'argent volé tout d'abord en
faisant un audit financier
un audit info lending audit c'est à dire
un audit avec récupération 10 ont de
l'argent et avec pénalité le problème
c'est que la classe corrompu qui est au
parlement qui est dans d'autres endroits
combat justement l'idée ils refusent
l'idée qu'il y ait un audit qu'il y ait
des réformes qu'on récupère l'argent
volé comment voulez vous que quelqu'un
qui a volé de l'argent accepte qu'on
fait de père cet argent alors qu'on
n'est pas logique
en tout cas donc donc ça fait cinq
semaines que l'autre ils ont bloqué
pendant cinq semaines et pendant tout ce
temps le dollar et monter la livre s'est
effondré les gens ont commencé à avoir
faim est en tout cas ce soir vous
craignez davantage d'instabilité
politique à l'heure où le liban on a le
plus besoin
écoutez moi je suis extrêmement heureuse
là derrière moi retenait derrière moi ya
pas de porte
ça a été soufflée par l'explosion je
n'ai jamais vu quelque chose
un état une situation aussi tragique où
les bras non je sais je sais que convoi
sans ressortir on va s'en sortir mais en
attendant c'est un moment extrêmement
difficile qu'est ce que vous voulez ce
que vous pouvez dire à quelqu'un qui
vous dit je n'ai presque plus rien qui
vous dit bon mois et notre mais notre
appartement n'est pas le seul à avoir
perdu ses vitres moi j'ai failli mourir
dans l'attentât heureusement je n'étais
pas là un quart d'heure près mais il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas de quoi réparer
leur leurs vitres d'un univers qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire
alors il le cinq semaines où le
parlement a discuté pour empêcher le
gouvernement de de faire son audit de
conclure le le plan avec le fonds
monétaire international tout ce temps là
a été perdu pour la population et vous
imaginez pendant cinq semaines de pertes
les gens qui s'ils ont besoin de manger
et qui finalement achète les denrées à
plusieurs fois le leurs prix vous me
demandez ce que le gouvernement a fait
part par exemple ils ont subventionné
accompagnés de 300 d'henry c'est c'est
pas idéal mais au moment où les gens
n'ont plus de quoi manger il ya eu une
fonction qui était fait dans les
réserves
avec l'idée que on va redresser
l'économie et on pourra s'en sortir mais
avec ce qui arrive maintenant je ne sais
pas du tout et c'est pour ça que vous
avez ces démissions là parce que ce
gouvernement est venu ce sont des
kamikazes
aucun d'entre eux n'avait envie d'être
nommé vous savez moi j'en connais
quelques-uns ils ont accepté parce que
il n'y avait pas moyen
c'était l'idée quoi on laisse le chaos
s'installer et puis se faire insulter
pendant sept mois
voir le dollar monte avoir affronté le
parlement pendant cinq semaines alors
qu'on sait que telle était et elle ont
volé et qu'ils ne veulent pas justement
que l'audit les découvre et fassent la
vérité et permettent aux payer de
récupérer l'argent parce que je récupère
l'argent on peut payer la dette
merci à d'autres pays de dévoiler les
comptes mais là on va on va continuer
d'en parler à merci lina mur n'est mais
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue